alors je voudrais que tout le monde
chante avec moi parce que le premier qui
chante pas il va payer la tournée
générale en sortant ouvrez ouvrez la
cage aux oies c'est pas assez fort
regardez s'envole et c'est les enfants
les
ouvrez l'oeil
pas
un petit et à coudre et trois poteaux
dedans tu du perchoir un os de seiche ou
blanc
et il ya sans cesse de le dire
c
jamais
dans la m
c'est ce que vous diront quelques
rentiers wisla et vieux schnock qui donc
d'être ou perdant sega
une fois en recul
pas de com
faites un truc qui vous rendra heureux
avec moi ouvrez ouvrez la cage
oui pourquoi
les enfants
et
où
l'apport de mai
votre concierge fait cuicui sur son
balcon avec ses perruches importés du
japon
c'est qu'à la rijole
des bengalis avons tous fait leur
quilit-quilit
sournoisement exclamé vous dieu quelle
plus moche mais chère madame
on vous demande au troisième étage et il
est klein pignol orale de tous
même si on doit pas vous lui pardonner
ouvrez ouvrez la cage aux oiseaux
regardez
voler c'est
il est
ouvrir la porte de
m
et
hélas cageots
oiseaux
il
c'est
les enfants
il existe
je ne
ouvrir la porte de mai
m
ouais
oh
leur théorie de faire tous ensemble sur
des décors quand j'arrive en principe à
l'hémicyle tafer alors tu es la corrida
soit la fête au les efforts on se marre
comme des mouches d'accord je vis chez
ma maîtresse mme habib el adli koshita
des pv
l'équipe des pilotes alors la folie
emma b
mais bell où la mer
pour les de presse
mes mollets essonne coma
c'est pas top
toulouse
bel exemple est la malgache de maîtrise
elle râle
la molina
les mam était ma vitesse de fou bezonnes
tonia web laisse de la pièce à
l'escalier
il est injuste qu'un bar
mes cousins sommes pas trop vite elle me
téléphone pour attaquer la musique où
elle est
alors
j'ai ma maîtresse
ma maîtresse la divine a dit à l'ats la
vie tu sais c'est pas trop ma venue
victimes
et qu'ils ont mis les beaux cheveux pour
être l'un des mots
paris
quand d'ipad dans le 16ème en bagnole et
que fo
mais tous plus barrés mali d'espagnol
une jolie et ans jusqu'en bas
et puis
comme li na
il s'agit d'un puits oui bien crado où
les mecs par-dessus galant nous sort un
srec loison khrouchtchev maison un
bordeaux pas piquée des hannetons temps
en temps en vieux pulls à ce qui s'offre
un vieux jambon vieux beurre effet une
nana une jolie drolet ce qui promet des
monceaux de karen o tord boyaux le
patron s'appelle we know elad la grèce
n'allait tiff des gros points noirs sur
la vie bruno fay le menu et le sait les
premières douleurs ou des scènes laisse
comme à genou qui demande pardon
les boyaux qui tricotent des napperons
les rotules de grand mère c'est du
beurre ajouter les biftecks phone vapeur
dit avant d'entrer et reste une molaire
à conseils tu la laisses au vestiaire au
tord boyaux le patron s'appelle bruno sa
femme est morte ya trois mois
nulle sert à l'estomac
dans le quartier même le moelleux d'où
tu ne risques pas d'entendre miiaou des
greffiers mignon n'y en a plus b f
ils sont tous devenus terrine du chef je
me souviendrai longtemps d'un gazier qui
voulait à tout prix du figuier
il chute avant de sucer les eaux les
moustaches en croix sur le carreau au
d'ordre ailleurs le patron s'appelle
bruno il envoie des postillons tafer les
yeux dans le bouillon sois prudent franc
bien garde au froid page son camembert a
eu le retour d'âge avant de l'approcher
j'te jure que désigne ou alors c'est à
la sinusite comme bruno imbeault panaris
le médecin prescrit le bain marie
mais si vrai petit cement entame dans
l'assiette
ils le disent au chaud dans la
blanquette au dos royaume
le patron s'appelle renault bien qu a eu
mille mironton dans la gueule pleine de
boutons
il s'agit un oui oui bien crado où les
mecs par dessus d'un an d'où se rince la
cloison kotcheff maison à bordeaux pas
piquée des hannetons
cet endroit est tellement sympathique ya
déjà le tout-paris n'ira blip un petit
peu déçu de pas être invité ni film ni
par les actualités
jo ne pas qu'on s'appelle bruno halimi
de voir avant ils n'achètent la tuna
je vous décris une petite bafouille un
coup facile mourrons ici en et office
oignons c'est que huit ans mais je me
débrouille
je tousse un plus à cause qu'on avale la
fumée du sinn d'à côté
mais c'est en face pourrait jouer dans
la décharge municipale les jolies
mais petit
mais
et
comme à la maison
demain comme il fallait
maintenant on va faire les poubelles
les surveillants sont pas mises en iran
les trois quarts du temps visant comme
des queues de belles années
donner
mais bon
non
sur une chaise aux antilles fit dans le
lavabo chez le menton guidon vélo et
ouakka ninon père lachaise
les punitions sont plutôt durs de pions
il a pas son pareil
nous attachons plein soleil tout du
barbouillé de confiture
[ __ ]
à
se baigner c'est le coin tranquille
et les seules personnes y va on va se
tremper dans un pipe à eau sorte les
égouts de la ville
pareil en atos le diffus
ce journal petrus tout boutonneux il
soir avant de se mettre nu on compta
suis qu'à l'oral
et
j'envoie mes chers père et mère mais
baisser les plus distinguées qui tâchent
vais voir ma fiancée une guèye cas au
moins c'est dit bert je les tiens n'a
vraiment pas de chance on nous fait
jamais voyagé mais grand fibre à tanger
dans d'autres colonies de vacances
ces petits projecteurs qui sont joints
sur la trouvais plutôt jolie lily l
arrivée d somalie liddy dans un bateau
plein d'émigrés qui venaient tous de
leur plein gré vider les poubelles à
paris
elle croyait qu'on étaient égaux les lie
au pays de voltaire et d'hugo lili mais
pour debussy en revanche il faut de noir
pour une blanche ça fait un sacré
distinguo
elle aimait tant la liberté lily elle
rêvait de fraternité lily un hôtelier
rue secrétan lui a précisé allard yvan
qu'on ne recevait que les blancs elle a
déchargé des cachots ligne
elle sait taper des sales boulots lily
elle crie pour vendre les choux fleurs
dans la rue ses frères de couleur
l'accompagnent au marteau piqueur et
quand on l'appeler blanche-neige lily
elle se laissait plus prendre au piège
lily elle trouvait ça très amusant même
s'il fallait serrer les dents il aurait
été trop content
elle est moins beau blond frisé lilly
qui était tout prêt à l'épouser libye
mais la belle famille lui dit nous ne
sommes pas racistes pour deux sous mais
on veut pas de ça chez nous
réessayez la mairie
ce grand pays démocratique lily elle
aurait pas cru sans le voile de la
couleur du désespoir
là bas aussi ce fut le noie met dans un
meeting à memphis libye
et la vue angela davis lily qui lui dit
viens ma petite soeur en s'unissant la
moins peur des loups qui guette le
trappeur et c'est pour conjurer sa
public qu'elle lève aussi un point
au milieu de tous ces gugusses qui
foutent le feu aux autobus interdit aux
gens de coeur et dans ton combat
quotidien elie qui connaîtra un type
bien l'idée et l'enfant qui naît un jour
or la couleur de l'amour contre laquelle
on ne peut rien on l'a trouvé plutôt
jolie lily l arrivée les somali midi
dans un bateau plein d'émigrés qui
venaient tous de leur plein gré vider
les poubelles paris
afin de nous obtenons complexe entré en
cure
gerland
lapan
sans passer devant nous est en cours
y compris
plus
sympathique
nous en explique tout l'amour qu'à quai
elle dit nous allons blanche
de la poire et l'inde à pau et au mur et
s'approche du tableau
maintenant
et laisse le monstre sacré cadeau pour
toi
soul saisie
et si
le vichot
charpy
toulouse
etc
aulas
sur le
bien grand mot
toute une région
oui mais le monde
de plus
les ia na toutes les couleurs ok ok et
voulant jusqu'au ramoneur ok ok je n'ai
vu des musiques qui grimpé dans les
qualifs en début de mois voire à se
tromper dans les godasses puis des
mécaniciens en détresse y ait jamais pu
réunir ses pieds
j'ai vu viager tout content quand je
sers aussi celui qui me donnent la main
ma soeur on est en guerre si c'est un
fake sortie chapeau violet qui juste en
pleine ascension et la génuflexion un
lever 6,6 au crépuscule et celui du pape
qui fait des flux le
farid et de montpellier
mais sur les
ceux-ci musclée chez le routier au pied
au but se reconnaît à son gros col romeo
caire avec chéri dauchy dois-je de me
casser des noix
je bois la pierre
vous savez
autre mesure le bouquin dans la
les
brider le mauvais
m
la saison de veiller davantage à bord